it's hard not to watch it as a
Libertarian and you know get get the old
uh blood pumping we've got a few clips
from his recent appearance on talker
Carlson show on x.com in September
following his first place
finish are are you arguing that
socialists commit Bloodshed because they
believe they are
God
om
for
it's it's you know it's exciting to hear
a political candidate pulling from hyek
books and essays and packaging it in
this really
fiery attitude uh but how much do you
think that this really these really
visceral ideological attacks on
socialism explain his appeal in
Argentina is that something that
resonates with the average
voter so I think that uh resonates with
his base uh and I think you know that
there's a very um there's a very
interesting feature in that clip which
is the sort of Christian language you
know that he uses when he talks about
Heretics and and capital sins you know
and and I think um I'm not sure about
this but I think this is part of a
strategy um in which mle is trying to um
sort of appeal to
uh religious people because they know
because he knows that if they believe in
him they will follow him you know no
matter what uh no matter what and and
that's you know I think he considers
that uh important for his political
campaign but I understand how that could
make a lot of people think that he's not
a true libertarian that you know that
he's actually uh a trumpan candidate or
a bonaro version U of artina um but I
think you know going back to to the
question of his you know ideology and
what does that have to do with his
success um I would say that mle
um owes his success mostly to
Argentina's failed economic policies
really because we are in a country that
has not grown in something like 15 years
you know we've been going from recession
to recession inflation has been um you
know increasing year to year and people
feel like um they have tried it all you
know that they have tried peronism that
they have tried anti- peronism back when
Maki was in power and that nothing has
worked and so people for example young
people um a boy who's like 20 years old
he was born in
2003 um everything he's seen you know
everything this person remembers of
Argentina's political life and economic
life is failure you know and so what
they're thinking is what is my future
look like in this country it doesn't
look good you know and so this person
what they want is they want to leave
Argentina and we're actually seeing that
you know I have many many friends who
have gone abroad and many who and many
don't think that they will return to
Argentina um and where do they you see
you know well they go so in Argentina
it's it's typical that many people have
um some sort of European citizenship you
know uh because of our heritage many
people have an Italian passport or a
Spanish passport and so they go to
Europe um some of them go us we don't
talk about that just kidding that's true
that's true too um but you know an
overwhelming majority is either Italian
or Spanish there are some Germans too
but they're not as many
some imagine how bad of an economic
situation it must be to be like I'm
going to leave Argentina and go to Italy
or Spain right like not exactly
countries known for their
industriousness and productivity and
participation in the right not ideal but
apparently better yeah so and so I think
you know mle feeds on that basically you
know on the lack of Hope of the people
and that's why he sort of presents
himself as a savior basically and this
can be you know this can be uh
interpreted in religious terms too you
know he I mean he he's never going to
present himself as God of course and
he's criticizing people who think that
they're God but he's sort of you know
trying to present himself to people and
particularly you know uh lower class
people people who have lost all hope
that he will restore you know Argentina
and and you can see when I talk about
this I think I I even think about how
this can be related to Trump you know
when he was talking about you know make
America great again um I think well you
guys know more about Trump than I do I
don't think America was never great
really but in this case it is true that
Argentina has lost something you know
Argentina used to be one of the richest
countries in the world and now it's just
average basically you know we don't his
attempt to lay this at the feet of
socialism and socialists is that
something that excites people or that
res that they resonate with um is that
something that kind of haunts the
political landscape whatever effect
socialism has had on Argentina because I
know we talked about peronism and it's
it's a little different it's this kind
of hybrid but how does that factor into
the political
landscape right so I think his um you
know his campaign against socialism uh
everything he says against socialism um
is is something that of course he
believes uh and that his base also
believes particularly uh the young
people you know students uh people under
25 or under 30 I don't think that's
something that resonates among um Lower
Class People for them I think the
message uh that m is getting to them is
that whatever is happening to them is
the fault of uh the political
establishment um which he calls Casta uh
right cast maybe the word in English I'm
not sure um but he talks about the
political cast you know he he says he
tells people that everything is uh the
fault of the political cast and that he
is coming to drain the swamp you know
like Trump did U Back Then in the US um
his message against socialism in
particular I think that excites uh a few
people not not the majority of his
voters but a key you know a key group
that is for example the group that uh
takes the lead on social media the group
that sort of sets the agenda on social
media and so when you go on Argentine
social media you will see that
influencers for example uh that like
Melee and talk against socialism are
hugely popular which is strange you know
because that's not that's not a thing
outside of social media really um and it
makes it look like it's you know this
generalized thing this generalized
opposition to socialism which I don't
think exists hey thanks for watching
that clip of our talk with Marcos
Falcone about the presidential candidacy
of javar Malay you can watch the full
conversation here or another clip over
here